new in theaters this weekend the wonder
park and five feet apart well you see
this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
well that didn't work out at least we
got dinner water park comes out this
weekend in this animated adventure
fantasy film super imaginative
ten-year-old future engineer June
discovers a real world water park in the
woods
[Music]
this wouldn't seem too surprising except
she spent her childhood building a
make-believe version of the same park
I like it when the ideas come from you
with the help of some talking animals
June must save the real Wonder Park from
the chimpanzees but showing no tea
this movie is for you if you're in need
of a feel-good imaginative animated
movie a story about dealing with family
challenges sounds good to you or you
just need some talking animals in your
life right now seems I have backed into
the middle of something backing out beep
beep I want to introduce myself
I'm well moving six feet apart at all
times both know the rules also out this
weekend a pull on the heartstrings
romantic drama five feet apart don't
tell me the one time you're interested
in some guy he's also got cieth this
love story is about two teenagers with
cystic fibrosis their love for each
other and how these challenges affect
their lives after all
and for me
I don't mind stealing something back
five feet apart is based on a novel by
the same name this movies for you if you
like relating to real life drama types
of stories you find young adult love
stories super cute or you're looking for
a good cry this weekend that is your
weekend ticket what will you see and
check back next week for Jordan peels
creepiest work yet
[Music]